so Liz I'm going to go back to about a
year and a half ago you're sitting at
your kitchen table working on your first
screenplay and I guess you say to
yourself Tom Hanks Meryl Streep Steven
Spielberg that's the that's the plan
yeah tell me what would the inspiration
was what were you doing when you sat
down to write it and what was the story
that you felt was important to tell you
know I am
I had just sort of I'd read personal
personal history by Katherine Graham
years ago and I just had sort of fallen
in love with her and always wanted her
story to be out there and I was sitting
at my kitchen table and I had been
writing for a while and had never really
gotten going and my husband actually
said write the movie about Katherine
Graham just just write it and because
that's what you care about you know and
that's what it was it was that was the
story I cared about I cared about her
because I saw myself in her I saw a
woman who was trying to find her voice
who had you know lived in a time when
women weren't supposed to happen yinz or
have jobs or anything like that and it
didn't matter that I wasn't 55 years old
or living in 1971 I still you know have
found myself in rooms of all men and and
had that so that was sort of where I was
starting and Amy this script comes to
you I think in October of 2016
barely a year ago it lands on your desk
and you read it and what's your reaction
there was a young man that works for me
who is very enterprising and stole the
script off some agents desk who Liz was
trying to get an agent that weekend and
he said I think that you're gonna like
this and I did and then I bought it and
then I called Liz and then Stephen
called me and said I think I want to
make this movie one of your first calls
is probably our conversations with Ellen
Lewis your casting director and things
have to move really quickly so tell me a
little bit the casting about Ellen's
role and how Tom gets on board well
Stephen gave the script to Tom and Meryl
and they
read it right away and that was on a
Friday and on Sunday they were making
the movie I don't think anything's ever
happened like that in the history of
movies the other thing was Steven I
think it was March 3rd where he called
and said I like this I like this I'm
thinking about it and we were shooting
in May so I I don't know if anybody else
in the world could have pulled that off
but Steven
it was quite miraculous I'd also say
like Christine Amy who put this movie
together in a way that I don't know that
anybody else could have in that amount
of time yeah that's true I interesting
because I had all women producers on
this and that is wonderful because
things get done when that happens you
guys sit around you know it kind of like
kibbutz a little bit too much but there
was there were a lot of fires being wet
and and of course the evening news was
lighting most of the fires but we really
felt that we could get into the national
conversation and make this movie as
quickly as possible and make it as well
as we possibly could if we had another
six months of pre-production production
and post-production time we still
couldn't have done any more than we did
to get this 9 months onto the screen and
Yahoo so much of this film is set inside
did you I was that how does that present
a particular challenge for a story like
this when so much is happening inside
offices inside homes inside houses
inside conference rooms I just think
that a physical aspect of of production
is never hard for me because I love
making movies and and this start was a
such that dictated itself to be inside
so that's not really difficult to to
approach the biggest aspect of my life
is of my professional life is to find
the visual palette that I can put in the
screen so the audience can understand
what I'm trying to do and making the
visuals particular lighting relevant to
what's happening right now you know
we're all talking about the movie
looking like 1970s and I can I feel a
little bit like a favor because I wanted
to look like 19 this night 2017 you know
it's so relevant to what we're going to
resonation but at the same time once you
have great makeup once you have great
actors great wardrobe great props and
cars you know you put the camera and it
looks like 1970 so you really don't have
to force the period in fact I had to
restrain myself too
more relevant to what's happening right
now with stylistically in the movies so
it doesn't feel dated because it's such
an essential aspect of my job to make it
current and relevant to - to the current
audience Rick so much of the production
design is focused on the mechanics of
what it takes to put out a newspaper the
press is the line of type machines the
composing the newsroom was that
something that you and Steven talked
about very early on about feeling the
actual texture of the newsroom almost
the smell of the ink and how a newsroom
actually cuz I remember when this
happens the newsroom vibrates when the
printing presses start turning no but
good question no III think it's really
hard and it'll be like this for me
anyway I just have to say to address the
the that the technical specifics of our
crafts that then because we were so in
the service of not only trying to make
it real for Steven and and Tom and Meryl
and all the actors when they'd come into
their environments but to set a tone
that you you could say it's impossible
to actually visualize this but I think
what you're hearing here is we know how
to do jobs and we do those jobs the best
we can and we communicate sometimes
without talking and we get in there and
we and we do the work but in many ways
that's like the newspaper business and
getting in there and actually the
filmmaking process that we had on this
was very much like getting to the truth
getting to the source getting to the
authenticity and that's that could be
difficult if you look at it as a sum of
lots and lots of details we have such a
great crew of mostly women from New York
and particularly Rena DeAngelo the set
decorator and the art directors that
just gave themselves a thousand percent
to this movie so that what happened was
we all found that we were doing this
about something and I and I think that
that it's a story of conscience and this
is how conscience works somebody does
something McNamara for whatever reason
was having that study made Ellsberg got
a little bit of that and thought I got
to do something
with this then the newspapers picked it
up then more newspapers and then finally
the nation so when I say that I have to
say that because that's how we made the
movie we all knew that this is what we
wanted to make the movie about and then
we all brought everything that we could
to bear in our various crafts and art
form Tom I want to ask you as an actor
working and Rick sets and with Ann
Roth's costumes and about how much that
helps you and how much the actual
verisimilitude of the newsroom help it's
priceless it's absolutely priceless so
much of what actors do is is based on
what these environments and particularly
costumes do to your muscles you cannot
wear these pants in these shoes and Roth
will put you through three hours of just
seeing the proper width of a collar and
you end up giving yourself over to
you're almost like a blank canvas and
she's prettier your your your your
modeling clay because she will find we
like we had a discussion of asses I said
we said look you know Ben wore these
kind of like those double knits
sansabelt slacks kind of things from
this and and what is it his ass looked
great
he had a barrel to end he said well
first up first up mr. Hanks he had a
great but then it then it ends up
bleeding into what why does he wear
these clothes what what is this style
that he has he rolled his sleeves up
perfectly he smoked a cigarette
perfectly and she says walk with me walk
with walk walk for me try these shoes
and walk so you're walking huh huh huh
do the thumbs do the thumbs and then I
do the thumbs and the pants if you know
huh uh-huh
I don't like the shoes that she was not
right try these do you know why Ben Ben
owned the room when he walked into it
you know why Tom and I said because he
knew and Ann said because he knew
and that's the it's not it's not just
fabrics its she's read it she knows it
she studied the man to posture the the
the gravitas and she does that I mean I
can't she's not represented here but
Steven started calling her his
co-director no I called her my boss I
absolutely what when I first met her
Merrill's have wanted to brought her in
and introduced me to her and she said
well here's what your movies gonna look
like and she did a 10-minute monologue
about the way the film was gonna look
and I just started calling her boss from
that day on Amy I'm gonna follow up on
something tom was talking about we're
all talking about it that's the women
who made this film you producer
Christina Costco Krieger Stacy Schneider
at Fox Ellen Lewis and Roth Liz your
screenwriter Meryl obviously why do you
think Kay's story and the women who made
her story is so resonant and important
to tell today well I think there's a
scene in the movie where she's in the
boardroom and she knows the answers to
all the questions and she's studied
really hard she's studied more than
anyone else has and she says the answers
under her voice and she's can't get the
words out but she sort of whispers them
and then someone else says them and says
yeah right that's what it is yes and I I
have had that experience I think any
woman in this audience has had that
experience when the whole entire company
is working for you they're still not
listening to you that's not so
far-fetched and that scene and the way
that Stephen did it and the way that Liz
wrote it was so resonant for me and so
resonant for Stacy it was one of the
first things that we talked about
because women still haven't found their
voice they still haven't found a way to
talk about how they feel and what
they're thinking and you know we started
this long before you know Hillary was
gonna be the president and Harvey
Weinstein was still running The
Weinstein Company these things are true
always they've been true
for a very long time and I'm going to
ask you this this last question about
the relevance of this period film today
and what it has to say about the
importance of a free press and the way
in which the press was under attack back
then the way in which it's under attack
now and what you would hope people would
be encouraged to think about after they
watch this film
you could you could possibly take all of
the articles of the Constitution and put
them on a different piece of paper as
long as you have that first article
which is freedom of freedom of speech
freedom of assembly freedom of religion
and freedom of the press
you could probably extrapolate all of
our American democracy
from that one article because it's based
on common sense and it's it is also
guarantee it's there's a reason those
guys put it first because up and to that
point governments could throw people in
jail if they weren't the right religion
if they printed the wrong stuff if they
said the wrong things or if they hung
around with the wrong people the very
basis of who we are is as a country is
based on our ability to think and read
and hang out with and worship as we deem
it to ourselves in the interviews that I
saw of Ben Bradley he said well you know
that the Pentagon Papers now if you
would if you look at it you'd probably
say well what's the big deal it's a old
study it's old news it doesn't mean
anything but they were gonna try to shut
us down over old news it doesn't make
any sense
well that's almost a quaint innocent
naive take on what is day in and day out
now an assault on in the truth and their
I'm sorry there is only one truth but if
if it is put out there to say I
understand you have your facts I don't
believe them well that's like saying 2+2
equals 5 and that's something George
Orwell wrote about in big bro
so it is it is as relevant as can be and
this is what great filmmakers great
writers great producers great artists
and a one time celebrity actors who when
they decide to tell a non-fiction story
Daan fiction put out a piece of
nonfiction Entertainment Act that is
based on something that happened fifty
years ago it can happen and have
happened 150 years ago it actually
speaks to that almost that biblical
sense of vanity of vanities all is
vanity is nothing new and there's
nothing new Under the Sun the good news
is is that we all know what happened to
Nixon it took a while but that very same
Constitution and that very same first
article brings down tyrants and it
brings down those that are trying to
obfuscate the truth and put a stain in
the pure water that is the United States
of America thank you all for coming out